para hablar de salud en directo américa
dejamos a por un lado un momento la
pandemia de kobe 19 porque hay novedades
en los estudios de las enfermedades del
corazón y las mujeres un estudio de más
de 2 millones de mujeres en suecia pero
dejemos que eso nos explique la dueña de
esta sección ya llegó la señora más
romeros mar espero que ya hoy se
encuentre muchísimo mejor de esa vacuna
contra el eco bit 19 pues le dijo esta
sección en sus manos por suerte ya estoy
recuperada aunque ya sé que te gustó
hacerlo sólo ayer si como decía este es
un estudio que implicó a más de 2
millones de mujeres durante más de 40
años por lo tanto es un estudio masivo y
la principal conclusión el titular
diríamos es que los partos prematuros de
las mujeres son un riesgo a largo plazo
de hipertensión lo publicó la revista
llama de cardiología son muchos datos
muy interesantes que precisamente para
ampliarlos estamos con el doctor oscar
franco director del instituto de
medicina social y preventiva de la
universidad de berna muy buenos días del
doctor cómo está cuéntenos cuáles son
las principales conclusiones y los
principales datos de este estudio
y algunas que me gustaría enfocar en la
primera es que encontraron que más o
menos un 10% de los partos que salvaron
en este dos millones de personas que
observaron un 10 por ciento eran partos
prematuros y partos prematuros quiere
decir que duran o que nace el niño antes
de las 37 semanas de gestación realmente
un parto dura 40 semanas esto es muy
similar a los niveles que se tienen a
nivel mundial también se observó que un
17% más o menos de las mujeres que
siguieron durante 40 años desarrollaron
hipertensión por lo tanto no recuerda lo
importante que es pero ni la percepción
porque es bastante común en tercer lugar
lo que se encontró es que las mujeres
que tuvieron parto prematuro tenían un
mayor riesgo de desarrollar hipertensión
y ese riesgo era mayor en los primeros
10 años y con el tiempo iba descendiendo
y va reduciéndose pero continuaba
incluso después de 40 años e incluso
después de tomar en cuenta múltiples
factores adicionales y por último lo que
se observó también es que a más temprano
con el parto prematuro mayor el riesgo
para tener hipertensión arterial después
doctor los saludos no tuvimos que
esperar hasta la semana que viene para
tener con nosotros nuevamente a marc le
pregunta ahora cómo puede impactar el
estudio en la atención médica a las
mujeres
sí yo creo que esta información lo que
nos está invitando a revisar la forma en
que estamos mirando a las mujeres cuando
hablamos de enfermedad cardiovascular y
de riesgo cardiovascular el parto
prematuro la historia reproductiva de la
será ginecológica de las mujeres debe
ser observada debe ser detallada y
registrada para poder evaluar y entender
que posiblemente personas o mujeres
pueden tener mayor riesgo de tener una
enfermedad cardiovascular a futuro y
mejorar la prevención en esas personas
entonces nos puede ayudar no solamente
para predicción para pronóstico pero
también para mejorar la forma en que
estamos previniendo las enfermedades del
corazón en las mujeres ahora doctor a
qué se debe esta relación entre la
hipertensión y el parto prematuro
esto no está muy claro todavía hay
varias hipótesis o rutas que podrían
identificarse como posibles mecanismos
que llevan a este problema en primer
lugar es posible que el parto prematuro
per se pueda generar un problema de
inflamación en el endotelio que es la
una capa que cubre
las arterias y las venas que tenemos y
esto llevaría a largo plazo a la
hipertensión arterial y luego
enfermedades del corazón por otro lado
es posible que este parto prematuro
simplemente sea un signo que nos está
dando enciendo temprano de factores de
riesgo adicionales que ya estaban ahí
que también llevan a la expectación
arterial y que luego llevan a la
enfermedad del corazón por lo tanto el
parto prematuro sería un signo de alarma
que nos está diciendo que hay algo que
estaba cualquiera de los dos se tienen
que evaluar con más detalle porque es
difícil de evaluar son pocos los
estudios que tienen tantos años de
observación pero lo que sí nos da de
información es que el parto prematuro es
una señal que se tiene que tener tomar
en cuenta para la prevención de las
enfermedades del corazón en las mujeres
doctor aprovechó para preguntarle
precisamente las enfermedades
cardiovasculares son la principal muerte
causa de muerte para las mujeres en todo
el mundo a qué se debe eso
si generalmente se ignoró la enfermedad
las enfermedades del corazón como un
problema que afectaba a las mujeres se
asociaba con el típico hombre adulto que
fuma el ejecutivo que está estresado
pero en realidad lo que tenemos es que
mueren más mujeres por enfermedades del
corazón que hombres y que si miramos en
riesgo durante toda la vida es el mismo
para los hombres y para las mujeres para
desarrollar la enfermedades del corazón
lo único es que las mujeres se dispara
después de la menopausia durante esa
transición menopáusica y se presenta
muchas veces de forma distinta eso hace
que sea difícil de diagnosticar lo
identificarlo y eso ha llevado a que
muchos médicos o personal de salud no
identifiquen los factores de riesgos
relacionados con las enfermedades del
corazón o las de enfermedad per se en la
mujer entonces faltan estudios falta
información alrededor de este tipo de
dolencias en las mujeres
por supuesto y no solamente en este tipo
de violencia en investigación
generalmente en todos los niveles
celular animal ser humano ensayos
clínicos y observacionales lo que hemos
visto es que la mayoría de los estudios
utilizan células especies o tejidos o
participantes que son masculinos y no
mujeres y lo que se hace se toma la
investigación que se obtiene de toda
esta población y se le aplica tanto los
hombres como las mujeres como si fueran
lo mismo entonces tenemos que mejorar la
participación de las mujeres en todos
los niveles de investigación que tenemos
ahora mismo pues doctor muchísimas
gracias por información gracias por
compartir nuevamente este espacio de
saludo con nosotros vamos ahora a seguir
nuestro programa directo américa con
nuestro segundo invitado al día gracias